m
lagence soleil a soufflé ses dix bougies
ce jeudi 27 octobre aux archives
départementales
une agence immobilière à vocation
sociale qui gère les biens de
propriétaires privés pour reloger des
personnes en difficulté pour l'occasion
l'exposition dix ans de savoir vivre
ensemble a été réalisé et aujourd'hui
c'est la fête sincèrement le bilan il
est très positive c'est pour ça qu'on a
voulu organiser cette fête autour elle a
besoin de nos valeurs que savoir vivre
ensemble
en fait tout une exposition avec les
locataires qui ont participé à des
ateliers photo c'est l'outil qui ont
voulu réfléchir à cette thématique de
savoir vivre ensemble alarmant président
de l'agent soleil mais également
conseiller départemental étaient
présents pour l'événement là on arrive à
ce que les progrès étaient privés
fassent confiance à lagence et qu'on
puisse les mettre location permettre le
relogement location à des genres grande
difficulté c'est sale c'est ça la grande
réussite de lagence c'est augmenter
l'offre de location et à côté des
logements sociaux
les bailleurs sociaux pouvoir leur
proposer des logements dans le parc
privé 10 ans d'existence et un bilan
très positif
aidé par mois un rôle important d'avoir
le ballon et a été à l'origine la libye
assuré c'est madame dindar qui de
l'époque
à déclencher le fautif a créé pour
l'agent soleil c'est à mettre à son
bilan est aujourd'hui le département
finance conséquemment suffisamment à
l'agent soleil aux côtés de l'état
l'exposition donnera lieu à la création
d'un catalogue qui reprendra l'ensemble
des illustrations et commentaires
présenter hésité à 1000 exemplaires et
véhiculera la valeur du savoir vivre
ensemble